welcome to this video playing L
marmalade yeah this is alma mater remov
one of the yeah one of the veteran
grandmasters from other by John he's an
old term acquaintance of garry kasparov
IAM he played many training games with
Kasparov when he was a junior okay what
do we have here some old Indian type of
position this stuff like night age for
here 44 and I'm not quite sure so if all
that will drop back okay Kim play Bishop
g4 bag how I didn't the bishop is not
really well placed on d7 some kind of
curious how he intends to set up his
pieces with 96 or something he's playing
quickly that much is clear Nyjah 4s I
know not not really good i think it's
not helping like very much okay so
should i go d 5 or not i'm at some point
I probably have to play the move so I
might as well do it here yeah well III
before is the normal way to proceed of
course can also get the night over to d3
first right okay that's prepared in the
queenside play before it's not possible
here I can go be 3r ever
just doing it in a slower slow fashion
yeah I did never play age three or
something because I thought that the
night has to retreat anyway and it in
fact it did um so look B 1 and four
possible before before is hanging I did
I did I make a mistake here possible
Quincy tutors see takes see takes Knight
takes e4 silly tactic it was bad you
should have made appt reflective
prophylactic move first if you now place
he takes I have to play move that I
don't want to play Knight takes d5 for
example but okay it's not it's not the
end of the world I can can play that
until before it's still possible but he
has Bishop a 4 and 9 a-4 things
interesting I came here very place a
queen d 8 at some point and I'm not
totally sure what to do then my mighty
for porn is Sam is under attack by this
song by this good night mmm not good
I really don't have a good movie i have
amazing i have some really substantial
problems here with the pawn for queen
bee 1m not very beautiful but i think o
Queen B 6 Bishop c4 not good that's
really not nice yeah I made a big
mistake there I think that this is kind
of opening with 94 and stuff this is
really not any good for black but I've
made a really wrong decision that
allowing 95 so easily that help like in
or sleep really enormously queen bee six
gem sure Pam maybe Bishop e3 but Bishop
c4 yeah I have to do this this kind of
oddly moves but it's not terrible it
seems i'm slightly uncoordinated but it
does not seem to be that much of a
problem at the moment he does not have a
brutal moves like on f5 so something
that sort of tries to exploit my
temporary lack of coordination and here
I'm totally okay again this is just the
keep it simple way not sure if it's
really that great to trade him but check
it should it should be okay ok it's idea
is Bishop da to be six probably
having some play against the b5 point
it's hard to how to invade him yeah it
is
trying to go to be three time working
yeah this trade is this helpful fem but
it's not not terrible for me check I
take that black resign some some games
are really strange I was really thinking
what is he doing on c3 yeah I mean he
has really no way for this night to ever
go anywhere and then if I'm 92 just
giving away giving away this piece yeah
I actually think it's about equal here
he has no problems whatsoever of course
but I don't think I'm worse I mean you
can do this for example f3 and I have
like this this skinny 292 at the right
moment may be king over to d2 it's just
equal it's nothing going on but I played
it a plated bad layer around him the
move here rook be one was a very sloppy
move I have to do something else and I
know what Bishop may be looking 11
interesting interesting moment is here
when I went went be three it is maybe an
idea to do this after I had to get the
night on d3 where it looks at those
squares are before and c5 maybe yeah but
this is this is not that terrible for
black yeah i mean why it has a slight
edge but it's not i overestimated this a
bit during the game because it looks
really weird yet to play Bishop back to
d7 and then 94 but a 5 9 a-6 makes kind
of make some sense am so it wasn't it
wasn't that bad as it as it unfolded he
was totally okay and it took me ages to
find who
see one or two except let's hit it I
have nothing better but here it is ok I
with Queen B 1 i'm getting out of the
sensitive see file and it should be
alright maybe you can do this yeah this
could be an idea before 93 yeah the 90th
this is quite good night here covering
the C 1 square well this is good for
black young that's a good position this
is an improvement for him to get get a
good game and yeah to before I should be
ok but I should never win this but you
just blundered this ok well thanks for
watching